how many days bro just tell me not a lot
bro
403 yes that's right jinxy has well over
a Year's worth of play time in Rainbow
Six Siege 403 days is almost 10,000
hours in the game 10,000 hours is the
number that author Malcolm Gladwell
believes it takes to become a master of
anything like getting as good as Bill
Gates is at computer programming for
example just to put this into
perspective finishing High School from
start to finish takes around five ,000
hours jiny could have graduated twice
and still have some time left over he
could have watched all of the MCU movies
138 times in 10,000 hours he could watch
all of One Piece Naruto and Dragon Ball
Z combined and still have time left over
so you got to wonder in all that time
has he actually mastered the game know
oh the stairs stairs right there on pink
where